I'm okay yeah look I can see right now
you're smiling and I'm smiling because
I'm with you
sure and I'm coping everyday you know
that's basically about it everyday you
just take it another day yeah to be here
with you and Alec I don't even know how
I got it but every day right you know
how do you get it about that's slowly a
lot of times I just want to go back to
sleep
yeah I want to dream yeah they're the
best of whatever you are comfortable
with and to the best of your ability I
have the same questions which is that
the fans have which is what happened it
was an accident
a tragedy yeah basically that's about it
I mean i emotionally can't go there sure
want to go there and it's you know the
tragedies that he's not here yeah and
that's that's all I know
yeah to go through something like that
privately is very difficult to go
through it publicly was there a point
where you accepted the outpouring where
you accepted the fans reaching out it
did go through a moment a point in time
where I just closed all the doors locked
everything down shut it down I wanted to
be isolated and then I started sort of
getting on Facebook getting on Twitter
reading all the the letters that
everyone grossed and there was a massive
outpouring which was so fantastic and I
would just want to thank everyone for
doing that and that did help because it
was all like Steven keep going we're
behind you you know don't just appear
yeah because that's part cause you want
to
yeah you do know for me it's been 28
years so I'm doing within 20 years so
that's all I know
we were kids we grew up together how
would we
we were 20 you were 20 yeah and he was
from the East Coast right the fresh from
New Zealand we were like just foolish
kids yeah
we literally moved in right fresh off
the start never look back at what point
do you go from being able to grieve to
try and rebuild still doing that still
doing it still there yeah no one
couldn't do be pushing like yeah you
should do this Italy no you do what you
do when you want to do yeah did you
think you'd be able to no no moving
forward with relaunching the website you
are back with a full line full Home
Collection line do you still run stuff
by own you don't agree by yeah yeah yeah
you know I talk to him all day every day
Christmas essences I was there his his
energy is always there you know we never
forget him our brand team is very
conscious of keeping him present yeah
there are a few things sometimes it will
be like I hate this let's do it you know
are you going to get back on television
yes I can say I'm going back to TV
whatever we're back to a new show it's
gonna be a daily show it's gonna be
multiple it's with multiple hosts which
I'm excited for I'm kind of nervous
yeah but I'm excited and I just hope
everyone that is there for him how would
knowing Christopher the way that you
know him the way that we all know what
would his opinion of the attention
but this sort of his spiritual nature
you know and him he would he would want
me to be or he'd be proud of me or or
really nowhere yeah yeah yeah thank you
so much I really really really love you